so we've been tracking the rise of Elizabeth
Warren in the 2020 Democratic primary for
awhile.
Now, I already already
told you that, uh, Joe Biden has had a sort
of up and down polling sequence.
Bernie Sanders had some ups and downs in his
polling.
Elizabeth Warren on the other hand, has had
a slow but steady climb from the sort of four
to 5% range to roughly 10% now, which is where
she is as of the latest polls.
And she's been doing it not with extraordinary
flash or viral videos or whatever else.
She's been doing it by campaigning substantively
and doing interviews where she lays out substantive
policy doing town halls and talking to all
sorts of voters, including right wing voters
in red parts of the country.
And I like the fact that this is what she's
doing.
I don't know if it'll carry her through the
nomination, but I liked the fact that this
was her approach.
And over the weekend she did a town hall in
Oakland, California, where 6,500 people showed
up to see Elizabeth Warren.
This was at Laney College on Friday night.
6,500 people waited in line outside the venue.
The entire thing was delayed an hour because
there were so many people trying to get in.
And once again, it was a super substantive
event based on policy and ideas.
Elizabeth Warren talked about her proposal
to end corruption, her proposals to cut money
in politics, proposals that would directly
help the middleclass.
Actually not like Trump's tax plan, uh, student
loan debt proposals, gun violence related
proposals.
The only thing about it that you could criticize
is that because it was so busy and it started
so late, she ended up not taking questions
from the audience.
So it ended up being more of a rally or speech
than it was a town hall.
Uh, so I want to give you the pros and cons
of what's going on here with Elizabeth Warren.
So as someone who has been running a substantive
issue based campaign, I love to see Elizabeth
Warren draw these types of crowds.
6,500 for someone who is, yes, she's a well
known senator, but she is not the sort of
cult of personality, a celebrity that some
other people in politics are.
I think it's absolutely fantastic.
I've also been critical of Elizabeth Warren
before, even though I love her policy ideas
that she is not the most likable or the most
relatable candidate at the large level.
I have seen her relate to people individually
in a way that is quite relatable and makes
her more likable.
But to see a huge crowd of people fired up
by campaign finance reform or ending foreign
influence on our elections by foreign countries
dealing with structural inequality.
It's awesome to see people fired up by that
and turning out by the thousands to hear her
talk about that.
And so there are two ways that this could
go for Elizabeth Warren and the next few months
if Elizabeth Warren can keep gaining the one
to one and a half percentage points per month
in the polls, which is roughly what she's
been doing for the last several months, if
she can do that and outlast the people that
are pulling 1%, the people that are pulling
2% who are going to start dropping out either
by choice or by force as the Democratic National
Committee's primary, uh, primary debate requirements
go into force after the second debate.
And then in the third and fourth debates,
uh, she could end up in a really strong position
by the time the fourth debate is all said
and done in October.
And then it's a question of who does the progressive
vote sort of coalesce around?
Does it coalesce around Bernie?
Does it coalesce around Elizabeth Warren,
who I believe clearly are the Non Biden front
runners at this point in time could change,
but that's what it's looking like right now.
Um, that's one way it could go and maybe the
debates would help her achieve that.
On the other hand though, as I said, what
I see as Elizabeth Warren's biggest weakness
is she doesn't debate very well, especially
in a debate with a whole bunch of other people.
I don't know the first debate, there's so
many people, they're splitting it into two,
like a first a and first be debate, and I
believe it's random.
I don't know how many people will be on each
one of those debates stages.
I don't 100% know how she gets the exact right
type of attention in that format.
That will advance her campaign significantly.
And part of it is she actually can go deep
on a lot of these issues, right?
She's got the right ideas, she has the experience.
She clearly has the intelligence.
The fact that the worst Trump has been able
to do with her is color.
Pocahontas and talk about her native American
DNA fiasco, which was a fiasco.
The way it was handled.
That actually suggests to me that Republicans
are kind of scared of her when you look at
some of the issues that the country is dealing
with right now.
And you look at Elizabeth Warren's experience,
her work in consumer and financial, uh, the
CFPB FPV consumer financial protection bureau.
When you look at her work on, um, income inequality,
it lines right up with some of the biggest
problems that we're facing in the United States.
And the fact that all the [inaudible] has
been able to do is say, Pocahontas suggest
to me she could do really well against Donald
Trump.
And not that Bernie wouldn't as well.
So I think it'll be very interesting to see
how does her message come through in a debate
because it does not allow, especially with
however many people is going to be eight or
10 for each of the two, uh, debates.
I don't know.
I don't know if she can go into the depth
that is required for her to appeal to people.
If you go to her rallies, she's going into
detail about her proposals and talking to
voters about them.
And that is part of why she hasn't been gaining.
We'll see if that translates to the debates.
And for me it's more a question of the dynamics
of the Democratic primary and just realizing
that in these large, massive formats, she's
not the most relatable.
She's not a particularly good debate.
Or once we start the debate phase, which is
in a few weeks, it's the debates themselves
that are going to influence the next several
months of the campaign and probably have a
significant role in defining who ultimately
wins the primary.
My concern is it's not Elizabeth Warren's
area of expertise, but I'm sure that she knows
this and that she's preparing in person.
She relates really well to people.
Maybe less so in debates with 10 other people.
Uh, I, I'm curious to see what people in the
audience think about this.
You know, unlike Hillary Clinton who narrowly
lost in 2016, Warren is actually further to
the left.
Unlike our 2016 nominee, Hillary Clinton.
Warren doesn't have the investigative baggage
around her.
And the admittedly fake but impactful scandals
that Hillary had, like Ben Gazi and the email
stuff.
So there's every indication to me that Republicans
would rather not have Donald Trump run against
Elizabeth Warren.
Uh, but let me know what you think and let
me know what you believe the debates will
bring.
I know that there are people who vehemently
or vehemently, um, disagree with me about
what the debates will bring and how they will
affect polling, but let me know.